I don't think he will I think he'd be
crazy to to do so uh and I think he
conflict if he did I think what would
happen is that he would immediately
tender Russia's resignation from the
club of civilized Nations it would be a
total disaster for his country so the
the current economic punishment that the
West has been able to dish out would be
massively intensified Russia would be
put into a kind of cryogenic economic
freeze and I think he would lose a lot
of the kind of Middle Ground of of
global uh tacit
acquiescence that he's had I mean if you
look at sub-Saharan Africa you look at
Latin America look at Lula for instance
uh who's just been elected again
look at South Asia
there's there's a lot of of willingness
to give Putin the benefit of the doubt
that will go the minute he does anything
uh like that he would also crucially I
think lose the patronage of the Chinese
and above all in his own country I think
he would trigger an absolutely
hysterical uh reaction
well our security and defense editor
Deborah Haynes who will be right here
this evening is joining me now from
Westminster Deborah what did you make of
what uh
Boris Johnson had to say
it takes a lot of sense in terms of the
catastrophic impact of Vladimir Putin
choosing if he did you to you to break
the nuclear taboo and launch a nuclear
weapon on Ukraine he does underline that
he doesn't think that Putin would do
that but the president has made no
secret of the fact that he is a nuclear
power and concerns have been growing
that backed into a corner with his
troops doing so badly on the ground
perhaps he would resort to a nuclear
weapon but as Boris Johnson said the
backlash from that would be huge not
just from allies such as China but also
those those in between countries that
don't know whether they want to support
Putin or not and most of all in terms of
the western Nations the Prime Minister
say it or the former prime minister
sorry saying that that the West would
have to retaliate to respond and it
would take the war to a whole new new
deadly level
and Deborah is there any understanding
at all of how the West would respond if
heaven forbid that happened
most western allies have been very
careful to stick with this policy of of
deliberate ambiguity about how they
would respond they've said that there
would be severe consequences they've
suggested that there could be some kind
of physical response which would
potentially involve military troops NATO
troops perhaps responding France however
is a bit of an outlier remember it's one
of the three NATO powers that has
nuclear weapons the French nuclear
weapons aren't part of the French
nuclear deterrence it's a independent
nuclear Arsenal but the French president
has recently said quite clearly that
were Vladimir Putin to use nuclear
weapons in Ukraine or in the region then
France would not retaliate with its
nuclear weapons obviously nobody wants
to talk about the potential for a direct
nuclear retaliation but clearly setting
a red line line like that is perhaps not
helpful given that the rest of his
allies the UK and the US have
deliberately not said how they would or
would not respond specifically